you know after your whole experience
through you know being incarcerated and
accusations and everything do you where
does do you have like who do you who do
you blame the most do you feel like oh I
think you might be surprised that you
know as much as like the blame game was
happening at me I don't really think of
it in terms of blame you know I don't I
I had a long time to like sit in my cell
and wonder why this was happening to me
and you know that's still a question
that bothers me like just why me why me
of all people in the world to have this
happen to them why I don't have a
sufficient answer for that but I don't
think that it's a specific person that I
feel the need to blame I think human
beings fail to see each other all the
time every day and it's not like it's
someone's fault you know I'm trying to
like one thing that I'm doing right now
is I'm trying to reach out to my
prosecutor because you know the the easy
and automatic response to any of these
situations is to be like [ __ ] that guy
he's a bad dude and he did something bad
to me
right but I've never found that to be a
very satisfactory answer to why it
doesn't answer my why question oh yeah
you know like it gives you like kind of
a like a cane a little bit but it
doesn't really give you like a real
place to stay in kind of yeah and I
don't know if it's just my disposition
but I don't like lashing out does not
feel satisfactory like doesn't satisfy
me in any way possible I think I
remember like one time wanting to like
punch a pillow once and I was just like
oh and it was like for some stupid thing
like maybe like traffic or something and
and I was like oh that's what everyone's
feeling all the time wanting to like
punch something like now I
what that feels like um so I don't know
I I it was there like but I I guess I
mean also like in a sense of like was
there a group that or and not even a
specific group or a person but was it
more like the the country was it more
the was it more the the media what was
it the news was it the the police there
that that was the thing that you're like
they it seems like they were the ones
that kept the ball rolling because it
seemed bizarre that you were going
through all this I think from you know I
consider myself just kind of an everyman
it seemed like like you didn't seem like
somebody that would kill someone to me
easily and even with it with the
information from the case but you but
you probably displayed behavior I was
like oh if I think you know she seems
like someone that's a you know unique or
aloof or whimsical and I could see that
kind of fitting like obviously a wild
story but was it more than media that
kept you that do you think one of them
influenced more the fact that you were
you were stuck there for so long that
you had to go through all of this do you
think um I think that it's like
everything it's a lot more complicated
than it would be nice if it worked
because it's a combination of factors
it's a combination of the law and like
what what was legally a lot what the
police were legally allowed to do with
do to me were they illegally allowed to
psychologically torture me in an
interrogation room well yes and no were
were they are they human beings and is
their instinct to feel confirmation bias
and to only see what they want to see
and sort of ignore disregard things that
don't go with their pre with their
prejudice like these these are all
factors that came into play and I can't
just pinpoint one reason why it happened
you know it's a lot of reasons do you
feel like that they that they started to
think that it was sexy that they had not
sexy but that it was
you know there was it was I think sex
played a role but again not just for one
person because like there's the
journalist who goes here's this like
here two fresh-faced young women and and
now it's sex on like girl-on-girl crime
and that's sexy and then on the other
hand there's a you know some police
officers or prosecutors who are looking
at a crime scene and looking at a body
and seeing that there were signs of
sexual violence and so getting this like
sexuality in their head and coming from
a different culture and a different time
than I was and and and having pre
judgments about my own sexuality or the
way that my sexuality even appeared to
them because they didn't even really
know right what kind of sexual person I
was they just kind of assumed things
based on the fact that I was an American
girl right and so there's a lot of that
that goes into play do you think that
they start that the that the police
there started to kind of get off on the
attention that they were getting at a
certain point and played into their own
like almost like they would keep up
things keep up the narrative and not and
you know not veer off and not even one
of your off because it gave them it
almost romanticized their position
that's what I'm trying to say I think it
probably had more to do with them
wanting to protect or you know they
wanted to maintain that they were
professionals with integrity and when
they're when their humanity came into
play when their prejudices came into
play when they made mistakes like many
of us admitting that they had made that
mistake like they can say like for
there's this cognitive dissonance where
they can say I'm a professional and I'm
acting with integrity and and in a
certain moment for some people like they
get on the defensive and they say that
therefore I cannot make a mistake like
how can you point to me and say like I'm
a professional with an integrity how can
you tell me that I made a mistake and
it's like well I'm sorry you made a
mistake it's ok you made one yeah yeah
but like it became
issue a benefit Kant became the blame
game like very quickly it became well
whose fault is like this is a [ __ ] up
situation whose fault it is like whose
fault is it and under what light can we
cast like how [ __ ] up the situation is
because we start with this death of a
young woman yeah and there there's no
escaping that this is a tragedy and this
is this is the story of young women
throughout history being targeted and
abused and and murdered because they're
really taken they've taken it's a matter
of the death they have and and like and
so we start with that and then it
becomes a tragedy on top of a tragedy on
top of a tragedy and and how the focus
gets turned from one thing to another
could you see how they transpose that or
did you think that they just it was
mostly just malicious I mean I think
that most of it was some something that
people were projecting on to me and I
was a convenient canvas for that because
nobody knew who I was right like I was a
nobody and so that meant that I could be
in anybody and then once people decided
what that person was like having that be
corrected like you know yes you you see
me right now I'm this is how I am and I
honestly feel like a lot of the negative
things that people have felt about me
have been a projection of their some
something some kind of like nightmarish
imagination that they have they've just
projected on to me because again it's
like a confirmation bias you see what
you want to see and if you want to see
like someone could look at me right now
and say oh I'm sitting I'm daring to sit
here like talk talking to someone as if
like I am NOT a [ __ ] murderer and
like me I'm just constant like just my
very like a lot of people feel that my
very existence is an affront to
Meredith's memory and that like the very
fact that people even know my name and
and know that I exist
is an offense that I am that I am
committing against Meredith's family and
so like when my own just existence is a
problem like anything can be a problem
right so Oh must be sort of is it
sometimes a battle to get going every
day in some ways like our is it like our
just some days it just kind of you kind
of have moments where it just you forget
that not forget but I never forget I
don't think I'll ever forget but my life
is not just what other people think of
me yeah fact the majority of my life is
not that the majority of my life is who
I love and and and what what work I'm
doing because I love the work that I'm
doing it's the question of now what and
and the the beautiful thing about my
life right now is I'm I can ask that
question and I suppose the question
never fully went away even in prison I
was thinking well I guess this is my
life I didn't think this was going to be
in my life but how do I like how do I
live my best life and so brave I don't
know I mean it's that or kill yourself
like that's good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one